bonsoir le 78 lactu sur TV fil 78
nouvelle édition il est 18h si vous nous
rejoignez en direct en ce 28 mai voici
les principaux titres la Fédération des
agriculteur vient d'organiser son
assemblée générale annuelle le thème les
médias comment les actions de
mobilisation sont relayées par la la
presse comment faire passer leurs
inquiétudes à Versailles va se dérouler
le Solar d'cathlon à partir du 28 juin
prochain lancé en 2002 par les
États-Unis cette compétition
universitaire internationale ambitionne
de développer des projets d'habitat
utilisant le soleil comme seule et
unique source d'énergie les cultures
urbaines à l'honneur à plaisir pour la
première fois à travers un festival il
s'était achevé il y a encore quelques
jours concert CELAM initiation à la
danse Hipop ou des spectacles pour
enfants proposés à l'initiative de la
municipalité une image pour débuter
l'image de cette voiture qui rle qui
roule uniquement au solaire 100 kmh en
consommant la même puissance qu'un
sèche-cheveux petit tour de force
supplémentaire ce véhicule est donc
aussi communiquant il peut gérer
l'information pour optimiser l'énergie
EOL c'est son nom et l'œuvre d'amis
ingénieur venu de bretag Bretagne
installé pour cette démonstration à
Versailles satori 150 personnes une
quarantaine d'entreprises des étudiants
ont permis son développement reportage
complet à suivre dans nos prochaines
éditions puisque nous l'avons bien
évidemment essayer on reste dans
l'énergie solaire avec le Solar
d'cathlon un événement d'envergueur
mondiale qui mobilise tous les 2 ans
alternativement aux États-Unis et en
Europe des entreprises des étudiants
autour d'une idée simple et si le
solaire était notre seule source
d'énergie des maisons sont créé des
plans jusqu'au dernier coup de peinture
de finition cette année ce sera dans un
lieu tout trouvé à Versailles dans la
cité du Roi Soleil un mois de ce qui
restera tout de même une compétition par
équipe la préparation se poursuit
reportage
pour nous c'est essentiel de montrer que
versaill au fond que l'on présente
toujours comme cette ville glorieuse du
passé c'est également une ville moderne
une ville moderne qui s'apprête à
accueillir 20 équipes universitaires en
provenance de 16 pays elles se mesuront
à partir du 28 juin à Versailles autour
d'un concept de maison solaire autonome
en énergie à un mois du lancement un
partenariat avec DF a été acté pour
cette opération on a créé un réseau
intelligent dédié spécifiquement à cette
opération nous avons installé un
transformateur au moyenne tension basse
tension de dernière génération et nous
allons mettre des compteurs
communicquants
Linky que nous allons déployer très
prochainement sur l'ensemble du
territoire national à partir de fin 2015
des bornes de véhicules électriques
seront aussi installés des testes
grandeur nature pour la société avant
une généralisation auprès du grand
public le RDF sera à l'issue de
l'événement capable de mesurer l'impact
d'un écoquartier sur son réseau de
distribution le Solar descathlon se
déroulera donc ici sur ce site dit des
matelots c'est un site important parce
qu'il se trouve à côté du château de
Versailles c'est une friche d'environ
100 heectares c'est un terrain qui
appartient au château de Versailles et
sur ce terrain depuis des années on
essaie de trouver des solutions et je
crois que là c'est une occasion rêvée
puisque c'est un financement qui vient
en grande partie de l'état et c'est
aussi l'occasion pour nous si vous
voulez d'aller plus loin c'est rec la
trame historique qui était celle
dessinée par le nôre seul point noir et
de taille l'absence de parking pour les
quelqu 250000 visiteurs attendus la
faute à une réglementation complexe la
ville mise sur les transports en commun
avec des navettes gratuites au départ
des différentes
gares agriculteur une profession qui
reste mobilisée mais aussi très
soucieuse de son image si les sujet de
contestation ne manque pas ils ont aussi
profité de leur assemblée générale à
louvcienne pour évoquer le rapport ort
au médias et le syndicat qui les
représente la FDSEA n'entend pas arrêter
l'action ce sera même son maître mot
pour les prochains mois clerire Cambier
Jonathan Vman la FDSEA la fédération
départementale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricooles d'Île-de-France
tenait son assemblée générale à
loupsienne hier l'occasion de faire le
bilan des actions menées cette année un
bilan en demi-inte leur principale
mobilisation apporté sur l'aménagement
de la PAC la politique agricole commune
les aides ont été remaniées cette année
la France a obtenu 63 milliards d'euros
pour les 7 prochaines années en novembre
dernier la FDSA avait organisé une
grande mobilisation le blocus de Paris
une action menée dans l'Ouest parisien
pour défendre les aides aux céréaliers
et alerter sur la surfiscalisation des
agriculteurs on a quand même un peu la
prétension de dire que ces ces actions
dures ont permis d'atténuer c'estàd
qu'on aurait pu aller encore beaucoup
plus loin la volonté du ministre était
d'aller encore beaucoup plus loin vers
une politique décroissante effectivement
là on a un système compliqué qui va nous
impacter directement va nous impacter
gravement et va impacter gravement
l'agriculture francilienne néanmoins nos
actions ont permis peut-être de pas
aller aussi loin que le ministre avait
envisagé dans lesivelin les actions se
sont également portées sur les
installations illégales de campement de
gens du voyage un dialogue a été établi
avec cette communauté et les autorités
locales enfin dernier point noir
l'entretien des cours d'eau et des fossé
de drainage traditionnellement effectué
par les agriculteurs eux-mêmes il est
aujourd'hui très encadré par les
autorités pour minimiser l'action de
aujourd'hui on sanctionne un agriculteur
à hauteur de 120000 € ou de 3 ans
d'emprisonnement pour avoir curé un
fossé ou un cours d'eau et ça ça nous
semble complètement il y a pas de mot
pour le qualifier c'est c'est c'est
complètement aberrant donc en fait il a
fallu monter très fortement au créneau
par rapport à l'administration mais
notamment à la police de l'eau l'ONEMA
pour la fédération qui représente les
1900 exploitations agricoles d'Île-de-
France les politiques environnementales
dans leur ensemble vont à l'encontre
d'un maintien de la
production je reçois à présent Colette
parent bonsoir vous êtes l'une des
responsables du MP dans le département
des Yveline le mouvement contre le
racisme et pour l'amitié entre les
peuples ce 31 mai vous allez fêter le VI
vivre ensemble avec nos différences un
message qui fait écho malgré vous
puisque ce n'était pas prévu à
l'actualité avec la montée du du Front
national quel est l'objectif de ce
rendez-vous justement c'est de de casser
un peu les préjugés de faire tomber les
barrières que chacun puisse accepter les
différences tout à fait oui euh casser
les
barrières lutter contre les préjugés
c'est effectivement notre objectif et
rassembler des personnes de diverses
origines des
associations bon beaucoup africaines
mais également les Caraïbes
euh le Maroc les associations qui vont
présenter ce qu'elles font dans
l'humanitaire et qui bah qui s'associe
avec nous pour dire nous sommes capables
de faire quelque chose ensemble et nous
avons monté cette fête tous
ensemble dans dans un travail de
coélaboration et voilà donc on CIT assez
content de de parvenir au bout sans
avoir rencontré beaucoup de de
difficultés et avec un certain
enthousiasme est-ce que vous constatez à
trappe justement où sera organisée cette
manifestation le rejet de ces différence
je vais juste rappeler que le Front
National est arrivé en tête aux
européennes dans cette commune est-ce
que vous voulez constater que sur le
terrain aujourd'hui vous vous voyez que
les gens restent chacun dans leur
précarré ils ont du mal à aller vers les
autres aussi oui quand même c'est
effectivement on peut pas nier que il y
a des replis sur sur soi c'est clair un
peu plus que il y a 10 15 ans euh la la
vie collective me semble un petit peu
plus difficile malgré des des efforts
euh mais
euh il y a quand même même un réseau
associatif extrêmement vivant qui fait
beaucoup de de choses euh ce réseau
associatif ne se rencontre peut-être pas
encore assez ne se mélange peut-être pas
encore assez donc ça passe par les
associations il faut déjà que les
associations arrivent à échanger à
travailler ensemble pour amener ensuite
les les citoyens eu à échanger alors ce
message militant vous allez le faire
passer sur un air de fitete un compte
chant défilé au programme quelles sont
les grandes lignes de la programmation
du 31 mai c'est à partir de 16h salale
Jean-Baptiste Clément attrape oui alors
c'est très varié les nous avons du rap
avec mes 1278 qui est un rappeur de
manthe Valentino bayamos qui chante de
la rumba
congolaise c'est vraiment des cultures
voilà un grand mélange on a un chanteur
de RnB afro qui s'appelle nel Boogie
black blomber la compagnie black blomber
qui vient également alors Ousman Dian
n'est effectivement pas vraiment connu
mais c'est quelqu'un qui va nous chanter
du réggaet parce qu'il est malien
d'origine et
il il chante il est guitariste avec son
ami ny trauré les poètes d'ici que vous
connaissez qui vont à la fois chanter
présenter des contes et des des poèmes
dans
l'esprit de de tous pareil et bon les
danseurs de fana c'est du folklore
capverdien donc on passe de tout à tout
he vous êtes en plan dans votre rôle
justement mélanger ces différentes
cultures c'est le rôle du merp quel est
le rôle du merap le rôle du merap c'est
de lutter contre le racisme et et de
lutter pour l'amitié entre les peuples
et de lutter contre les discriminations
nous dans notre association dans notre
comité local nous aidons nous nous nous
aidons particulièrement les sans papiers
à obtenir leurs droits au travers de
permanence que nous tenons euh à la
Maison des Associations euh attrape tous
les jeudis euh bon pas demain parce que
c'est férié mais tous les jeudis soir on
a une permanence pour aider les sans
papiers qui euh pour un certain nombre
sont régularisables et que nous
aidons dans leur démarche
à à à régulariser parce que c'est un
vrai parcours du combattant pour combien
de personnes vous aidz comme ça
euh
nous
envoyons une à 5 par semaine ça dépend
des fois hein et parfois on n voit pas
mais c'est très rare hein de toute
nationalité de toute nationalité
euh oui toutes origines alors bon sauf
un peu le territoire américain ça non on
n
pas il sont il sont pas migrants de ce
côté-là j' reviens à cette mobilisation
que vousz organiser cette fête du vivre
ensemble salle Jean-Baptiste Clément
attrape le 31 mai à partir de de 16h
jusqu'à tard dans la soirée il y a
beaucoup d'associations qui sont
mobilisés ma dernière question ce sera
de savoir s'il a un moment il y a eu un
peu de résignation aussi lorsque vous
avez vu par exemple les résultats aux
européennes frond national qui progresse
le manque de participation d'implication
des citoyens aussi aucune résignation à
aucun moment ah non nous on on dit alors
vraiment on s'attendait pas vraiment à
ce résultat euh surtout pas à cette
abstention mais on ne baisse pas les
bras parce que parce que les les gens de
trappe s'il ne sont pas allés voter
c'est parce que ils sont en plein
désarroi et que nous devons nous
contribuer à à leur donner un petit peu
d'espoir je pas à l'intérieur de ce de
cette soirée nous allons prendre un
petit peu la parole quand même et dire
ce que nous faisons donc
euh voilà c'est nous ne baissons pas les
bras il y a des causes assez assez
malaises et
assez ce ce il a il a un désespoir
quelque part un désarrois certainement
plus c'est plus le mot
euh mais nous ne baisserons pas les bras
parce que de toute façon le racisme qui
est le fond de commerce de Madame Le Pen
et je le dis en tant que MP parce que le
MP appelle justement au niveau national
à un front commun des organisations des
droits de l'homme
euh contre les les messages xénophobes
contre les
doctrine raciste qui se développe
actuellement donc il y a eu dès le
lendemain de de l'élection ce cet appel
à ce à à constituer ce front commun donc
nous nous y contribuerons le plus
largement possible et peut-être même
avec les pouvoirs publics s'il le faut
parce que ça doit cesser l'illusion
que les choses pourraient mieux aller
s'il y avait moins d'étrangers merci
Colette Paron d'être passé sur ce
plateau nous présenter
cette fête du vivre ensemble à trrape
merci à vousci culture et l'art de la
gravure dans l'atelier l'un des ateliers
les plus ancien de 5 an oneline visite
démonstration présentation des outils
explication des techniques des procédés
c'était dimanche dernier en cours à
l'occasion de la fête de l'estemp Aélia
debicii et le
dimine depuis 5 ans Yannick Dublino
enseigne les différentes techniques de
gravure au sein de l'atelier d'art
graphique de la villeedieu le cours de
ces lundi est exceptionnellement ouvert
au à l'occasion de la fête de l'estampe
une célébration nationale qui fait
référence à léit de Saint-Jean de l du
26 mai 1660 qui a reconnu au graveurs le
droit d'exercer leur art librement au
15e siècle l'estampe est un procédé de
reproduction d'image au fil du temps
elle devient un moyen d'expression
majeur pour réaliser des œuvres d'art à
part entière j'ai à cœur de que l'on
considère la gravure comme un art majeur
enfin majeur au même titre que la
sculpture et la peinture
et c'est en face de le devenir parce que
nous de nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreux à y croire et à développer non
seulement les techniques traditionnelles
qui existent mais leur aussi leur
adjoindre des des tas de découvertes les
graveurs sont des gens curieux sont des
gens qui expérimentent beaucoup et qui
cherchent à tout prix à à à se surpasser
aussi quelque part hein on se surpasse
alors ça ça peut être par des formats
pour certains ça peut être par euh pour
sur des différents supports pour
d'autres une estampe est l'empreinte
réalisée à l'ancre sur un support souple
plaque de bois ou de métal gravé pour
obtenir une matrice d'impression il
s'agit donc d'une image imprimée sur
papier qui peut exister en plusieurs
exemplaires à l'atelier de gravure les
artistes viennent par faire leurs
connaissances et leurs pratiques je
crois que ici c'est un lieu
de de liberté un espace de liberté
d'expression l'expression pure
c'està-dire que moi je suis là pour les
techniques et uniquement pour la
technique je ne vais pas du tout empiété
sur leur
domaine création je respecte
profondément intrasèquement tout ce tout
ce qu' recherche et je suis là pour les
aider Catherine Azou viler est peintre
et sculpteur depuis plus de 10 ans elle
a rejoint l'atelier cette année j'avais
choisi de travailler seul chez moi j'ai
une presse mais au bout d'un moment on
aussi de de partager de s'enrichir
deussi d'autres expériences d'apprendre
d'autres techniques ici j'ai découvert
le travail sur le bois pour moi c'est un
mélange de sculpture et de gravure
quelque part puison on entaille le bois
fait son dessin sur plaque de bois avec
des outils
spéciaux on taille on retire le du bois
on en retire le creux mais c'est pas le
creux qui sera ancré c'est le la surface
un stage pour débutants et
approfondissement de pratique pour
d'autres est organisé les 21 et 22
juin après la fête de l'estample la fête
de l'afric voisin le Bretonneux une
semaine d'animation central freine de
vini jusque au 2 juin bonsoir Céline
Sylvia vissence vous êtes coordinatrice
du centre Alfred devini juste pour
débuter un premier mot sur l'une des
animations qui a eu lieu cet après-midi
et qui s'est terminé ce sont des cours
de cuisine africaine ça s'est bien passé
elle est en cours encore he il cuisine
là jusqu'à 19h30 oui oui oui tout à fait
donc ça consist en quoi il y avait des
plates spécifiques à préparer voilà la
découverte de de plat d'un menu
traditionnel alors je me souviens plus
le pays exactement je crois que c'est le
Sénégal mais elle va peut-être le
présenter dans le reportage on va avoir
quelques quelques images pendant que
nous parlons effectivement est-ce que il
y a une une inscription massive est-ce
que les gens se déplacent est-ce qu'ils
sont intéressés par ces cultures euh oui
puisque en fait on traditionnellement on
essaie de mettre à l'honneur des des
cultures des pays hein donc donc là en
fait c'est un petit peu l'impulsion a
été donné par tous les ans on a une
soirée africaine qui est qui promet pas
mal de de choses et l'impulson a été
donné on s'est dit on va faire des
activités sur la semaine et la clôture
avec la soirée africaine on va venir à
cette soirée il y aura d'autres
activités d'ici là des sorties des
conférencesr programme il y a eu des des
sorties donc au musée du kbranly au
musée d'appur qui est un musée moins
connu un des plus grands d'art africains
sur
Paris on a eu aussi donc le cours
aujourd'hui la soirée africaine de
clôture donc je détaillerai peut-être
tout à l'heure et puis une conférence
sur l'orientalisme puisqu'on a des cours
d'histoire de l'art aussi en fait le but
aussi de la semaine c'était de mettre à
l'honneur toutes les les savoir-faire du
centre les intervenants et leur proposer
de mettre à l'honneur sur une thématique
particulière justement vous avez
sollicité les intervenants du centre qui
sont les intervenants donc on a Luciane
rinud qui est la professeur de danse
Afrique afcaine du Central Fred devin
nous avons Valencia aller qui est la
l'intervenante en cuisine africaine
euh voilà après qu'est-ce que j'oublie
pourquoi une semaine sur sur l'Afrique
comment est né cette idée ben c'est
vraiment l'impulsion du cours de danse
africaine qui faédère énormément qui
chaque année propose donc une porte
ouverte he c'est la la fameuse soirée
africaine et qui qui vient ou vient se
greffer des personnes extérieur des
personnes du centre un lieu d'échange un
lieu de
de création donc l'année dernière on a
eu du compte cette année on va voir un
défilé de mode donc inspiré de une
styliste contemporaine qui mélange
également des tissus africains il va y
avoir aussi une peintre qui va exposer
ses tableaux donc c'est vraiment le
l'échange voilà la rencontre des
habitants de culture et c'est vraiment
une belle soirée je vous invite si vous
avez la possibilité à participer alors
cette soirée justement comment comment
va se passer cette soirée donc elle va
débuter à 19h30 c'est c'est une soirée
donc vraiment conviviale et basée sur le
partage puis qu'on appelle ça un repas
partage c'est un buffet partage chacun
il y a pas d'entrée c'est une porte
ouverte pas d'entrée payante chacun
vient et apporte soit un savoir soit un
plat soit une une présentation donc la
compteuse vient va faire un compte les
danseuses de la du cours de danse
africaine font se promovoir voilà c'est
vraiment une une soirée conviviale et
une porte ouverte d'échange
régulièrement fr dein organise des
semaines sur des pays sur des
communautés aussi en dehors de l'Afrique
oui puis sur des des thématiques aussi
particulières qui qui émanent des
habitants puisque c'est un lieu qui qui
fait d're donc il y a quelqu'un qui va
venir et qui va nous proposer ben
j'aimerais bien parler de tel sujet
faire un débat là c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment on parle aussi parentalité ça
sera peut-être pour la saison prochaine
voilà c'est vraiment le le lieu où on
peut venir et proposer quelque chose et
on le met en place et pour continuer
cette saison pour terminer quels sont
les prochains rendez-vous peut-être
alors donc nous aurons les talent
d'Alfred donc c'est les portes ouvertes
de toute la saison et de tous les
ateliers les 20 et 21 juin h donc de
9h30 de 16h30 à 19h le vendredi 20 et de
9h à 18h le samedi 21 euh la brocante
qui se prépare la brocante de voisins
donc portée par les adhérents les
bénévoles du centre Alfred devini qui
organise sa tise du lien social c'est
les habitants du de l'avenue de la
Grande île qui viennent nous aider à
mesurer à tracer c'est vraiment et qui
viennent à la buvette aussi a
partager et puis ensuite nous aurons
donc la programmation des vacances au
mois de juillet début juillet voilà
comment se porte le centre peut-être
pour pour conclure si on fait un bilan
de de cette saison euh ben je dirais
bien il y a un renouvellement il y a des
personnes nouvelles il y a des gens
habitués des gens qui s'impliquent euh
des jeunes aussi on espère de plus en
plus des gens de l'extérieur aussi qui
viennent pas mal de la communauté d'aglo
puisquon on est on est ouvert à toute la
commun uniquement voisin le Bretonneux
mais a T 50 an voilà et puis il y a
cette semaine donc de l'Afrique qui se
déroule actuellement les renseignements
pratiques qui sont affichés n'hésitez
pas si vous souhaitez participer à cette
soirée de de clôture de cette Semaine
Africaine merci encore à vous d'être
passé sur ce plateau à Plaisir la ville
s'est offerte son premier festival des
cultures urbaines danse street art
concert proposé au cours des 10 derniers
jours avec la présence d'artistes
reconnus du milieu ambiance avec ce
reportage planche masque et bombes de
peinture la panoplie par fate du
graffeur dans le cadre de son festival
des cultures urbaines la ville de
plaisir a organisé un atelier graffiti
l'occasion pour petits et grands de
découvrir cet art urbain autour de
professionnels le graffiti c'est des des
lettres un nom sur un mur ou des dessins
sur un mur ou tout ce que tu veux sur un
mur de la peinture sur un mur chacun
fait comme il peut comme il
veut c'est voilà c'est c'est
l'apprentissage on fait tout le temps
nous ça fait des années il y a pas de
technique particulière ouverte
apprentissage et créativité le grap un
atelier très apprécié des enfants de la
commune le temps d'un après-midi ils ont
pu se mettre dans la peau d'un graffeur
on peut dessiner en toute liberté les
cultures c'est pour exprimer ce qu'on
pense dans la tête j'ai appris à faire
les traits à faire des graffiti je peux
essayer d'apprendre et ça me PLA
j'aimerais bien en
refaireonn comme art le graffiti
s'installe doucement dans la culture un
combat que mèent les professionnels du
Graf sur le graffiti il y aura toujours
une une connotation de vous faites de de
la pub de votre nom vous faites vous
allez dégrader en fait n'importe quel
support gratuitement alors qu'on en est
plus là c'est ça fait alle les 15 20 ans
que c'est fini qu'aujourd'hui on se bat
pour rentrer dans des musées que c'est
pas pour rien qu'on essaie que justement
les néophites puissent voir un peu le
travail qui est fait tout ce qui a fait
enfin tout ce qui est fait derrière quoi
que ça soit plus justement mal vu et mal
senti le graffiti moyen de s'exprimer ou
de communiquer depuis des milliers
d'années n'est pas prêt de disparaître
la relève est
assurée voilà pour la fin de ce journal
je vous retrouve vendredi même heure
d'ici là profitez bien de ce nouveau
jour férier si vous en avez la chance
très bonne
soirée